[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to fremont california
we're out here at the test track of our
fremont factory
just a few meters away from where we
actually build all of our tesla vehicles
we're super excited to have you all here
in fact
almost nine years ago
on june 22nd 2012 we had our first model
s delivery event
right over there in the factory
so we've come a long way in
a few years
we set out to design engineer and
manufacture
the best car in the planet and we've
been working tirelessly every day to try
to make that happen
and tonight
we're going to show you the next
best version of model s
[Applause]
and i brought this along
because we might be breaking a few
records
but more about that later
so let's get elon out here and have him
show you
how we made the best car in the world
[Applause]
the model s this is an ambitious goal to
create a whole new kind of car a lot of
wall street is betting tesla can't get
it done
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right uh thanks for coming and
thanks for tuning in
so uh as france was saying this is uh
nine years since we delivered the first
model s the first car produced here in
fremont so almost a decade
and uh i think we've really taken it to
a whole new level with the
with plaid
some of you may know that i mean
basically our product
uh
plan is stolen from spaceballs um
so
we're
we've gone plaid speed
[Laughter]
um so
uh what i really wanted to achieve here
is like well why you know why
make this really fast car that's crazy
fast and everything and
i think there there is something
that's quite important um to the future
of sustainable energy which is
that uh
we got to show that an electric car is
the best car hands down
you know
so
it's got to be clear it's like man this
is uh just
sustainable
energy cars it can be the fastest cars
could be the safest cars uh it can be
the most kick-ass cars in every way
um and that's that's why we did the
plaid it's just to show hands down this
is the way to go
so
um
yes
pressing slide
there we go all right
so
uh we've made huge improvements from the
original car uh and uh well actually
who here has anyone here probably some
have
bought the the early model s like the
yeah
little thank you for your support
um so
uh
what we've you can see the the huge
improvements we've made
so
and it started off with with good
performance but
uh now with the
with plaid we've managed to break the uh
the two second barrier if you will the
no production car has ever
uh
done zero to sixty in under two seconds
[Applause]
so and and this is this is a four-door
car these five adults uh
et cetera et cetera it's like you know
single movement i mean this is like what
i call a uh limit of physics engineering
it's not relative it's like uh what does
physics say we could do because physics
is the law and everything else is a
recommendation
so
in addition to uh
it's a crazy performance uh it's also
got a longer range even with the
tri-motor
high performance it's got almost a 400
mile range and in the dual motor
configuration it's got a 412 mile range
so
[Laughter]
420 give or take
so
um
that joke will never end
so and and we've also improved the
supercharging speed so you can get 187
miles of range in 15 minutes
so
[Applause]
yeah so a quickest production car to be
clear of any kind ever made like i said
first to ever break the two second
barrier
later tonight you'll get a chance a
chance to
uh
drive around the track and um
like this is really something you have
to feel to believe because it hits you
hits you right in the limit system it's
like damn like whoa
yeah
it is basically what is the car that can
how can we make a spaceship a car you
know
so
hello
the
see
yep
and then in terms of additional stats uh
it's also the the fastest production car
to complete a quarter mile so 9.23
seconds uh it's got a 200 mile an hour
top speed uh
a thousand over a thousand horsepower
almost 400 mile range like i said uh
charges
uh so fast
you know it'll be probably done by the
time you have a coffee basically
and talking about some of the
sort of
details behind it
so we have an all-new battery pack
and then something we're really proud of
is the new carbon sleeved rotors for the
motor so this is the first time that uh
there's a to the best of our knowledge
there's been a
a production electric motor that has
that has a carbon over wrapped rotor so
this is a super hard thing to do because
carbon and
copper have
you know
at very different rates of thermal
expansion so
in order to do a carbon overlapped rotor
you've got to wind it at extremely high
tension it's a very hard thing to to do
we actually had to design the machine
that makes the mot the rotor
so no such machine existed before it
also means we can make have the
electromagnetic field uh be super
efficient
and have a tight gap even at super high
rpm
and this is it's single speed from zero
to 200 miles an hour
so it's just
the rpm is so crazy that
just the centrifugal force wants to
expand the rotor so the carbon overlap
actually holds the the rotor basically
holds the rotor together
it's like
madness
so
um
yeah
so let's see
in fact uh we're gonna show you the
motor in fact you might have had a
chance to see the drive unit
and we can
go closer
i mean this is really an amazing work of
engineering
um
yeah
there's just never been a
an electric motor like this i mean you
can pick this motor up with your hands
and and it can accelerate a two-ton car
to 60 miles an hour in two seconds
i mean that kind of power to weight is
insane
so it goes uh
we've
it goes up to 20 000 rpm and maybe a
little more
so
we also were able to achieve the lowest
drag coefficient of any car ever made so
yeah
so
really i think tesla engineering has
outdone itself here
this is a car that looks good but also
gets an
incredible drag coefficient and this is
uh
this is the the true drag coefficient of
the car including um
with wheels in motion sometimes you'll
hear drag coefficients quoted but
that'll be without the wheels moving and
the wheels cause sort of error churn and
incremental drag
and uh this is the actual drag
commission of the car so it's uh
to have a good looking sports car
uh
at that lower draft coefficient is
really tough
so we also have the latest uh greatest
in heat pump which is the basically hvac
system for the car uh it's 30 better
cold weather range
and requires 50 less energy for cabin
heating and freezing conditions
[Music]
yeah so it's you'll see very little
degradation in cold weather
and the radiator is twice as big for
heat rejection so you'll be able to
actually do back-to-back 0-60s
go on the track just whole ass and as
you'll see tonight this car is going to
be over and over again and it doesn't
get winded
[Applause]
i think we got to take this uh back to
maybe the nurburgring
let's
see what happens
um and then of course uh
you know when we
first delivered the model s there were
no superchargers anywhere in the world
so back in 2012 no superchargers
anywhere
uh now there are 25 000 superchargers
all around the world
so
we opened uh 30 just in the last week
and
we're just going gonna keep going so
that you can basically travel anywhere
you want
uh
with peace of mind super easy keep
increasing the the power of the
superchargers uh you know we're 250
kilowatts so obviously that will start
going to
you know 280 300 350.
yeah
so
and then it's it's also engineered for
maximum safety as well
uh in fact this is designed to be
our aspiration for this car um it still
has to be tested by the us government
but we think we can get the the lowest
probability of injury of any car ever
tested
so
um in fact the these are the actual
nissa probability of injuries numbers
all top five cars
the with the lowest probability of
injuries ever tested all five are teslas
so
so
with the plaid model s what you have is
a car that is uh faster than than
quicker than any sports car
uh and like faster than any any porsche
safer than any volvo in the same car
that's insane it's like
like
you know
yeah
so
and then the design we've obviously made
a lot of refinements to the exterior and
and then we've made we've completely
redone the interior so we i think once
you drive the new model s it really
feels like you're driving the future
and
other cars are good especially like
non-tesla cars are going to feel very
last century
so all new interior
um as you can see we changed the
orientation of the main screen so it's
easier to watch movies and that kind of
thing um in landscape
yeah
exactly
i mean
in other notes we have ventilated front
seats
so
yeah anyway it's i think it's a it's
really
you drive around and it really feels
like okay we're in 2021 great
um we have the this yolk steering wheel
which is a little different but i think
once you try it you'll think this is
it's it's great um
the you you're the visibility
of the the main screen is super clear
especially for uh autopilot so you can
see the entire panoramic view of you can
basically see the mind's eye of the car
and uh
yeah it's
it's really cool
so
and then we've gotten rid of the stalks
so
like you know i think generally
um all input is error
so we want
if you have to do something that the car
could have done already
that should be taken care of
the software should just do it so you
can actually just literally walk up to
the car it senses that you're
approaching unlocks the car based on
your phone it just basically pairs with
your phone knows that you're coming to
the car opens the door it opens extends
the handle you sit down and you just
drive
you don't you don't have to uh press the
drive or anything like that the car
knows you want to drive the figure's
like yeah good guess you know
so
and
and then and then it's using the
autopilot system to know where the
obstacles are so obviously if there's
something in front of you you want to go
backwards and if there's something in
you know in back of it you want to go
front most likely um
and then it'll it'll it will adapt to
your uh
to your needs so if it sees that you're
always doing this you know
you're changing to reversal forward in
particular situations it'll try to
remember that
and geocode it to that location so then
you it'll you won't have to do in the
future it will just keep uh
minimizing the amount of input that you
need to do until the car just reads your
mind
so it's gonna be great
um
so uh we've redesigned the
the remove the interiors of the the
um the the front ip is actually
slimmer and thinner so we were able to
move the uh
the front seats forward giving more room
to the vaccine and we
reclined the back seat more and
reduced the interior trim so
uh basically the the current more or
less the back seat is not amazing but
the new one uh it's actually a legit
backseat i'd say
it's like
it's good
um
so you can it's i think it's quite a
comfortable uh back seat and you've got
also a rear screen um and you can
control everything from the from the
back
um
yeah
so
it's it's got uh uh
inductive dual inductive charges uh for
your phones in the back and dual
inductive in the in the front
um and it's a 36 watt power supply so
you can actually charge like your
you know laptop or anything basically
it's got it's a 36 watt usbc
it can also
pair with multiple bluetooth devices
simultaneously
so
multiple people could be controlling
music or somebody could be playing a
video game
so it's
you can do multiple wireless things
simultaneously
and then
similar to the the model 3
and why um we instead of having air
vents uh we use intersecting
uh columns of air so and we just vary
the the speed of the air so
you don't have to there's no vents
that you can see
and you can just touch the screen and
move the screen around and it'll it'll
just move the air wherever you want it
and the and the area is much more
diffuse
it just feels like an invisible air
conditioning system it's great
so
and it's it's a tri zone so there's a
zone for the rear and a front and left
left front right front zone
and then the 17 inch touchscreen is
it feels like a movie theater the sound
is incredible
um
and um yeah so
you can really it it's like a home
theater experience
so if you're if you're sitting somewhere
waiting or for whatever reason or at a
supercharger uh you can just catch up on
order your favorite netflix show or
itunes or whatever the case may be
youtube um and of course uh
you can also play video games
so and and the same thing for the rear
so you can uh rear
it basically the the system feeds all
three screens
um and so you can do things the front
rear that's great
um
we have an all new uh sound system
designed by tesla audio
um with uh and we have acoustic glass
throughout the car so the car is very
quiet when going down the highway even
at very high speeds like you're like
doing like 100 miles an hour still quiet
um
and this is a tesla designed uh codec so
uh it will keep uploading improved
versions uh of the sound system it's
it's it's completely software defined so
we'll keep tweaking it and dynamically
adjusting to whether
you're using uh streaming or whether
it's coming via bluetooth for your phone
or
different streaming services uh it'll
actually and if the data rate changes
it'll
adapt that so basically it always sounds
good
and that's just going to get better
so
yeah
and then we've got an all-new ui
so
really want waypoints
okay does everybody here want waypoints
all right fine we'll do waypoints
god damn it
all right
um
all right we'll do do away points fine
um
so
uh but obviously it also interfaces with
your calendar
um so if you just uh
basically just if you just get in the
car and you just sort of swipe down from
navigate you don't have to enter
anything just swipe down uh the car will
automatically figure out if you want to
go to homework or what's on your
calendar so it'll default to calendar
priority and obviously if you're if
you're at home and and it's kind of a
weekday or whatever it assumes you're
going to go to work so you just swipe
down automatically navigates to work and
checks traffic and gives you an optimal
route so it's just like a nice little
easy thing and you can actually set it
to automatically generate the most
probable route so you just get in and
it's going to guess what route you want
and you don't have to press anything
yeah
so anyway the ui is
like basically easy to move around uh
expand contract uh shift music to the
left to the right
and we're going to keep improving it so
it basically feels like a like a modern
tablet or phone um
and then
it's not ps
not ps4 ps5
so um there's
i think never really there's never been
a car that has state of the art uh
computing technology state-of-the-art
infotainment where
uh this is literally uh at the level of
a playstation 5.
so
yeah i mean
if you think about the future where the
car is
often uh
in
autopilot or full self-driving mode um
then entertainment is going to become
increasingly important so you're going
to want to watch movies
play games
you know use use the internet uh just a
little thing yeah things you want to do
if you're not driving
and
this is a
actual playstation 5 level points
so
we're going to try to do a gaming demo
yes it can play cyberpunk
so this is somebody playing the car
right now
this is so play playing live
yeah
so it's you know
like pretty great you know so
have fun in the game in the like it's
gonna be great
so
all right
so high frame rate will do 60 frames a
second
with state of the art games
all right so we've got uh
incredible performance interior of the
future i think engineering that's
practically alien um
so i like said the you know
simultaneously the safest crowd in the
world and the fastest it's this is
insane so
we also got like look at some things
like the uh the power curve
so the i think this really illustrates
the difference
it maintains a thousand horsepower all
the way up to
uh 200 miles an hour
this car crashes
all right
so
yes
all right and deliveries begin now
so we're in production uh we're going to
deliver the first 25 cars now and uh
and then
basically we should be at uh
you know
several hundred cars per week soon and a
thousand cars a week probably next
quarter so
uh please enjoy uh we put a lot of work
into this
uh like to to thank the incredible work
of the tesla engineering and production
teams
uh
[Applause]
it's like my hat is off to tesla
engineering production design the whole
the whole the whole group
uh they really put their heart and soul
into this so i hope hope you enjoy it so
let's deliver some cars
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you